محمد حمدان حميتي قائد القوات الدعم
السريع المجتمع الدولي الى تحرك فورا
وتدخل لوضع حد لما سماها جرائم الجنرال
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان الذي وصفه
بالمتطرف الذي يشل حمله وحشيه ضد الابرياء
ويقصفهم بالطيران حسب تعبيره وقال احميتي
الى يحارب الاسلاميين الرادي كاليين الذين
يامرون في ابقاء السودان معزولا في الظلام
متعهدا بملاحقه البرهان حسب وصفه واعتبر
ان حميد يعتبر ان المعركه التي تخوضها
وتدعم السريع هي ثمن الديمقراطيه نافيا ان
تكون قوته هي المبادره بالهجوم
ان الدعم السريع يتخذ كل الاجراءات
الممكنه لضمان السلامه وامنناس متعهدا
بحمايه الديمقراطيه ودعم حكم القانون في
السودان
ينضموا الينا من الخطوبه الكاتب والمحلله
السياسي صالح جمعه ومن الخطوط ايضا لواء
المتقاعد بدر الدين عبد الحكم الباحث
السابق في الاكاديميه العليا للدراسات
الاستراتيجيه والامنيه مرحبا بكما صالح
جمعه هذه اللغه التي
وصف بها حميتي البرهان كيف يمكن فهمها
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اول حاجه نحن
نتاسف جدا لاستمراريه الحفل الحرب للمره
لليوم الثالث
وكل المشاهدين التغيله جدا في كثير جدا من
المواقع
الموجوده فيها القوات
الحرب هي فيها كثير جدا من المشدات
اللي ممكن تجريبي في حاله
نفتكر لغه الحوار
السيد النائب والسيد الله حميدي هي كانت
لغه لغه الحوار العادي قبل الحرب الان
يصبح اللغه الحرب والحرب اللغات وعندها من
حج معين في اطار التعامل الوزاري لكن هذا
المضمون اخي الاول انا بفتكر ان المناشه
للمجتمع الدولي والمناشده لكثير جدا من
المنظمات والحاجبين على مصلحه الوطن ان
يكون في تدخل عاجل واخفى هذه
الحرب الليله اللي ممكن الان اصبحت تعاني
كما ذكرت المتحدثه قبل قليل ان الان في
كثير جدا من المصابين من
المعلقين وكثير جدا من الاضرار الاضرار
الاجتماعيه والانسانيه على هذا الشعب اللي
ممكن الان اصبح يبحث
من ابسط المقومات اللي ممكن الان لان كل
الجسور مغلقه بسبب هذه الحربه اللي ممكن
دائره في بين الدعم السريع المسلحه